[Music]
we're leaving Alaska and we're heading
to Washington State for the final leg of
our journey and sad sad to leave saying
goodbye to cousins here we are
yeah
[Music]
oh yeah look at those two poor man
yeah
[Music]
we're all the girls we're in the car
we're on the road for hours yeah the
traffic's pretty terrible Alexa isn't
here right now there's no Alexa here
there's no like so we don't even own one
[Music]
Canada
that's that's a national anthem a
hundred we gonna go a hundred just
kilometres I think 60 look at this view
not too shabby alright guys so we got a
room in the pinnacle hotel here in
Vancouver got a lovely view of the
harbor right out here it's just gonna be
me Tommy and Nathan Rebecca's got a
conference for work here in Vancouver so
she's gonna be staying in a separate
hotel that her office is work is paying
for and then we're gonna be partying
here just to block the shoe away so
we'll get to do some things with back in
the afternoon but the daytime is gonna
be me and these boys
well Becca's off with her parents
checked into her own hotel and it's just
me and the two older boys so it's like
10 o'clock at night so we're gonna run
until I knw and grab some food a couple
stags out on the town what do you say
guys
how you like in Vancouver so far is this
fun
yeah look at that big frosty root beer
for Dad
nice nice huh guys is this fun being
able to stay up late and eat drink root
beer with dad
yeah it's good a good time you guys want
to go swimming at the hotel it's really
late so we could do it anyways okay
after we quick though we'll only get a
little bit of time
[Music]
so I better get him to bed though and
get some sleep because we got a long day
tomorrow it's gonna be a lot of fun
[Music]
do we go we're gonna get him out of bed
get him some breakfast and we're gonna
bite good morning guys did you sleep
well all right guys you ready there's a
lot of bike rental shops in Vancouver
you can get electric bikes you can get
normal by skin fat tired bikes we're
gonna see if we can't get something for
the kids
there you go can you guys both fit in
there all right let's do this
[Music]
there we go you liked our ice cream
see the $1 coins gotta loon on it and
this is a $2 coin so it's a loony in a
toonie well this is how I like to see a
city you know I don't care too much
about the museums and all that stuff but
I'll be able to grab a bicycle here and
cruise around my little boys get some
hot dogs that's that's it's the way I
like to do it like your hot dog kind of
fun there's a ton of these parks along
the bicycle paths though you know the
boys have been eyeballing out of these
parks and finally we stop for lunch so I
just let him go nuts on this it's even a
few water parks we might go back and
visit you having fun buddy go boy
all right guys you ready to do some more
bike riding this place hey Tom is that
fun
dunno oh you doing goodbye
[Music]
well we're in Chinatown and Vancouver
and it's definitely different than the
rest of them Coover a little bit dirtier
a little bit sketchy but a lot of herbal
medicine stalls and little grocery
stores this place is messed up just saw
a couple guys buying and selling drugs
as a homeless type just did a line of
coke off the back of his hand not a part
of town I want my kids I'm getting out
of here well that was fun but we've got
two very tired very thirsty little boys
here so we are going to go up and find
some cold milk and some cold root beer
and then we're gonna go swimming oh
you're tired Nathan your legs are tired
all your head is tired it's sour patch
kids you know like the sour gummies okay
[Music]
all right everyone get your boots on
where you're gonna see mama well we are
out the door and almost out of the hotel
but one of us pooped his pants all right
so we have a historical reenactment of
the Bataan Death March here feel like
I'm going to beat dad come on guys keep
walking we Rebecca's dead all right
20th floor buddy whoa look at that view
literally there's a chocolate bar this
tastes like potato chips it's crunchy
it's got little pieces of potato chip in
it okay this has been some of the like
the worst food I've had it's gross it's
cheese speed - how can you freaking
screw up cheese pizza yeah and this was
the grossest juice it was told wrong
[Music]
babe
all right well Joe and Shelly want to
take a ferry across the northern
Vancouver so we're gonna do just that
we're gonna take the sea taxi defrost
[Music]
here we are on the north side of
Vancouver and we really don't know what
we're supposed to see I think mostly
Becca just wanted to take the taxi which
is cool so we're just gonna check it out
and wander a little bit and then head
back because it is already the kids
bedtime yeah you got food stalls food
truck concerts magic shows lots and lots
of people how are you guys hey Tommy is
the back of my shirt sweaty we got to
get to bed so I will see you guys in the
morning we're gonna do some fun stuff so
this morning's been off to a rocky start
so far we've had a temper tantrum about
wearing clean clothes temper tantrum
about not bringing blankies with us a
temper tantrum about standing and
touching each other so yeah coasts do
you like your breakfast good so we're
sitting here waiting for the valet to
bring our car around
but the parkings like 40 bucks today 45
bucks today Tommy are those horses cool
you know what I don't think Nathan likes
the horses as much who rode our bikes
under
this mat is awesome this is this is nice
[Music]
well guys we bought way too much stuff I
got sleeping bags and pads and shelters
and bags and everything for camping and
it's still cheaper than doing a hotel so
we got our camping gear and Nathan had
the biggest diaper blowout he has had in
a very long time I still can smell it
well we're gonna go and find a cool
suspension bridge you guys wanna do a
little hiking all right well guys we
made to the Capilano Suspension Bridge
Park where this is cool pedestrian
suspension bridge but this place is a
madhouse it is absolutely crazy packed
with tourists it's a Saturday so you
know kind of what do you expect little
fun fact I used to carve totem poles so
take it out of here this pole I'm pretty
sure is hyda which is a tribe on an
island a little bit north of here and
the pole over here to Tommy's right I
believe is Kwakiutl okay this place is a
bit of a tourist trap it's 46 Canadian
dollars to get in for one adult
luckily kids under six are free but holy
mackerel this place is crowded
okay so we're standing on line to go
across the bridge and this line is
massive I heard somebody say 15 20
minute wait
this moves around a lot
good because I'm really fat if you're
not a fan of heights you may not like
this at all
you guys having fun there's a whole
bunch of people fighting Jesus back
there yeah you got a good grip with your
dinosaur boots yeah there's a trout
right there there's a decent one that
one's good 15 inch err oh look at this
weird like a giant tree Fork
look how high this is off the ground
[Music]
look at that we are we are legitimately
high off the ground all right
fat dad on the bridge right yeah guys I
just got a text from mama she wants us
to come pick her up so we got to get
going guys all right tom
we gotta make tracks well that was fun
but definitely crowded and not cheap so
I'd come during offseason or at least a
weekday well guys we got Becca she's
done with her conference for the day and
believe this or not her birthday is
coming up soon she's turning 29 and and
we have for her birthday Becca wanted to
do like a flightseeing tour and we
waited until about five minutes ago to
realize that's what we wanted to do we
ended up finding a place in Squamish
British Columbia which apparently is the
name of a town north of us
going along the coast that the mountains
and the water and the crazy kids in the
back okay this is gorgeous
did you ask for better weather to go up
in a plane I'm really excited this is a
beautiful day and these mountains are
gorgeous I think this is gonna be a
pretty awesome a little sightseeing tour
we're gonna do all that down okay this
is this cool Becca are you excited
[Music]
yeah fun babe beautiful amazing I loved
it that was awesome
those are so awesome oh yeah
well guys we had a great time here with
glacier air a beautiful beautiful
sightseeing trip and way cheaper than
the other trips down in Vancouver so if
you guys want to check out more
information about glacier air here in
Squamish we'll go and put a link in the
description so check it out
here we are at the watershed grill rumor
has it that's a nice little place to
grab some food they told us it was about
a 15 to 30 minute wait for a table so
we're sitting here on a bench watching
the river and I just saw the sunset not
too bad is one of the best weights for a
table I've ever had it's taking a dust
bath come on buddy
up here so in a weird twist I bought
some butter chicken because you know
I've never eaten Indian food in Canada
before
[Music]
alright guys we got a little Mud Pie
action oh yeah alright guys come on well
I'm really glad we got out of Vancouver
I mean Vancouver's a pretty City it's
interesting but honestly most of stuff
there to do is not really up my alley
and the traffic in the congestion that
gets a little bit much it's nice to be
able to just venture out see you other
parts of British Columbia because it is
gorgeous smoke of nothingness that was
the entire world
my boys are tired so we got him to bed
and I'm tucked in and we'll talk to you
guys tomorrow I woke up this morning to
find my hotel infested with caterpillars
angry biting caterpillars are going to
church we need a good breakfast we'll go
to church and then we'll see mom and
have a good time okay Nathan's happy and
we know it alright guys we're here at
church you ready let's go well we had a
good time at church the boys were
marginally well behaved we're back at
the hotel and my boys have no shoes
where are your shoes well we're gonna go
meet mom for lunch here
just how they grandmother grandpa coming
to it little Jacob should be there
there's mama daddy's off hey babe okay
so we're here at an Italian restaurant
in Vancouver and so what do i order
pokey tacos that's raw tuna fish
Hawaiian style into tacos so there you
go
it is good holy mackerel those tacos
were good Tommy
look at that cheese sandwich look at
that big that is a loaf of bread it's
not as big as your head but it's darn
close here we go guys banana split with
cherry gelato whoo-hoo not too bad
Nathan when you think of that ice cream
you gotta work some of this bad off so
I'm gonna go on a very leisurely stroll
here around the bronze appear well guys
we are going camping tomorrow and we're
checking out tomorrow morning so I'm
gonna get all packed up but I'm tired so
we're gonna we're just gonna take a
little easy for a little bit rally my
strength
well I'm trying to get packed for a
camping trip tomorrow but this one is so
much a high-maintenance we're gonna try
to get to bed early the boys are tired
they've been up late I've been up late I
don't see you guys tomorrow
well guys it's our last day here at the
hotel and I just got the bill it was
shocking we're gonna go and have some
breakfast and then we're gonna pack up
the car and we're gonna get out of here
are you picking your nose
well it's been expensive but you gotta
admit this is a nice view
apparently there's a cannon right over
there on that far shore that fires off
at 9 o'clock at night make sure you eat
up our camping trip goes badly this may
be the last meal you have in three days
well I checked out of the hotel and I'm
1 and a half thousand dollars poor but
we had a great time it was a nice place
and now we're gonna go run to Walmart
pick up a few things and then I've got
to go hit a caviar store so alright guys
you ready let's go what kind of snacks
you guys won I don't know what happened
we were just gonna buy a few things then
all this happened well I looked up a
place online to buy caviar in Vancouver
sent me to this place the Intel
International House of caviar I caught
the owner at a good time nice Iranian
man I'd paid him a mixture of US and
Canadian dollars and I got myself a can
of caviar
so there we go some dry ice and caviar
that little can cost me a hundred bucks
alright we're gonna go find Becca for
lunch and
we're paying like 14 bucks for 90
minutes of parking here so all right so
we got mom's birthday presents now we're
ready to go beat mom for lunch to
celebrate Becca's birthday I bought her
three different types of non-alcoholic
cocktails so we'll see what you think
and we got a rope quickly before the
kids get it we've got some Korean short
rib sliders and some tempura shrimp
rolls with some chili sauce on them and
Nathan's eating American cheese mostly
with his fingers I having a good
birthday big
[Music]
so we're leaving Vancouver and heading
about two and a half hours east to
Chilliwack Lake Provincial Park and
we're gonna be camping there for three
days
[Music]
well I've seen about 12 signs now that
say campfires are banned
so apparently campfires are banned
pretty much everywhere but I am
determined to eat our hotdogs so we're
gonna MacGyver this son of a gun as best
I can and I'm gonna try cooking some
hotdogs here on the engine block I've
done this on some older model engines
before where the manifolds exposed but
it's got this cover on it which is quite
hot this feels like this is over a
hundred degrees right here so these are
precooked so we just need to get them
warm
get to using my brand new Japanese knife
- all right right behind the dipstick
seems to be the hot spot I think we give
it about 10-15 miles and it should be
perfectly cooked
then about 30 minutes now 30 minutes of
cooking time oh yeah that's the stuff
that's done all right decent you want a
hot dog stop throwing the rocks at the
car hey guys who wants a hot dog there
you go buddy
guys want s'mores I can't have it on
this one all right we got the s'mores
sitting on the engine block well let
that sit for about 10 minutes
more hmm there you go
not a bad engine blocks more mmm Sun
setting and I think it's pretty close to
the boys bedtime but we're gonna go
ahead and explore a little bit before we
call it a night cuz it's still pretty
light the boys ain't goin to bed with
this Sun up look at this look how big
this tree is look at that that's pretty
Nathan what do you think of this place
is cool guys it's past your bedtime we
need to go to bed and we're getting up
early tomorrow morning all right guys
let's go back up alright guys you ready
to camp you excited for tomorrow we're
gonna catch huge fish tomorrow okay
we'll have a good night and we'll see
everyone in the morning good night
thanks for watching and we hope you
enjoyed this video check out this sneak
peek of the next installment of the 2018
world tour
if you like this video log series don't
forget to click the playlist link into
the video description below thanks for
watching if you want to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click Subscribe
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning